- But since last time I saw you,
a lot of shit been coming up.
I said, "Damn, I should
have thought of that!
"I should have thought of that!
"I should have thought of this!"
- [Interviewer] So what's
been going on, Louis?
What do you want to talk about today?
- Well, I'll talk about
some of the issues I had,
a couple issues I had.
One issue that traumatized me,
as far as when I saw my
brother get hit by a car.
Another is my sexual addiction to this day
behind some shit that
some people did to me
when I was little.
- [Interviewer] So, what
happened to your brother?
- Well, I was about five years old,
he was about four years old,
and the ice cream truck would come down
the street all the time
and he would come on
the other side of the street of the house.
So, my mother that particular morning,
ran over to the ice cream
truck, but he ran behind her.
Now the truck is pointed this way,
and I'm over here on
this side of the street.
And I had seen TV but I'd
never seen blood before.
I never seen nobody actually
had got hit by a car
and got really fucked up.
And especially when I was young like that,
I really didn't know what love,
what the feeling of love or anything,
that I really love my brother.
Even when I'm talking about it,
it makes me want to cry,
because I remember extremely.
So my mother tells him, she says,
"Go back across the street."
And there's this guy, you
know how black folks are.
He had a low rider.
He's got his music up loud.
he's coming down the
street and all the sudden
by the time my mother
says, "Run back, run back."
He runs back in front of the truck.
And all I remember is
the noise and seeing my brother,
and everybody going like this.
And I remember when he
landed in the street,
he like bounced a couple of times.
And I remember my mother
ran out to get him
and she had him on the sidewalk.
And I remember my mom going into shock.
She had my little brother in her arms.
She's said, "Don't die, don't die."
I remember me and my mother
we were just shaking.
Then she went, the ambulance came
and they come there to give
her some kind of sedative
to calm her down,
and they were talking
about giving me something,
because I was just, I
didn't know what to do.
I didn't understand my emotions.
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- So I was five, 'cause he was four
and I remember they had
this little girl next door
and it was a babysitter named Sonya.
We had to go to her house,
while they went to the hospital.
So, Sonya had this rocking
chair, this old rocking chair
and when it rocked, it had
a chime on the bottom of it.
You know like the chimes,
when you have the boxes do,
where you open the box,
ding, ding, ding, dong
and the little ballerina goes around?
And that particular chair had
this music from that chair
and I remember that song went on,
and she was rocking, and that song went,
and I was visualizing my
brother flying through the air.
As old as I am, when I talk
about it, it still hurts me.
And I remember I told her,
"Stop rocking in that chair!
"Just stop!"
And so anyway I guess about a year later,
I didn't know how that really effected me.
They had a new Sears and Roebuck
that opened up over by the mall.
So, we went into the Sears and Roebuck,
and so my mom and my sisters
are looking at these things,
when they have the perfumes
and medications they have in there.
So they open up this box
and there's this little ballerina girl
and she comes up, bing bong!
And she goes, ding, ding,
ding and I hear that song
and I remember my mother asked
me, "What's wrong with you?"
And it's like all that
came back and I said,
"Close the box, momma, close the box!"
She said, "No."
So my sisters they started to open.
Anyway I took the first one they opened,
I picked it up off the shelf
and I remember I broke the
glass on the Sears shelf,
and I ran and there
was the women's section
and they had these long gowns
and I ran up under the rack and I hid.
I was just shaking.
I remember they went and
got the security guard
and they had to have two
security guards. (laughs)
It's kind of funny now 'cause I remember
I was holding onto the pole.
And they had to have two security
and they were pulling me
out, "No, no, no, no!"
'Cause I kept visualizing my
brother get hit by a car, man.
God, and just like when
I talk about it today.
My poor brother, the
blood gushed down his head
and was all over and I
remember when my dad,
my father he was a fucking asshole,
when he came home, he beat my mother.
He came up, "What happened
to my fucking son?
"What happen to my fucking--"
- [Interviewer] So, did your brother die?
- No, no, he didn't die!
He didn't die.
It took him a few months but he recovered.
He's doing real good now!
You can still see the bruise on his face.
Anyway, my father comes home that night
and I'm laying in bed,
'cause I never could sleep
and I'm laying in the bed, and he says,
"What happened to my fucking son?
"What happened to my fucking son?"
He grabbed my mother, "What
happened to my fucking son?"
She said, "He got hit by a car."
"No, he didn't, you fucking bitch!
"You pushed him, pushed him"
And bam, he hits her in the face!
And I remember he threw her over the,
back in the day they
called it a wifi stereo,
I remember he tossed her
over the wifi stereo.
She comes to the wifi stereo,
she tries to hit him back
and he grabbed her and he
pushed her down on the ground
and he puts his foot on her neck.
He had her and I remember
I was standing there
and my aunt told me, "Go get
a knife out of the kitchen.
"Go get a knife out of the kitchen."
So I run to the kitchen
and get there and I said,
"Get off my momma, get off my momma!"
So he backhands me, bam!
He backhands me.
I'm laying on the floor
one more time. (laughs)
It was kind of funny,
but when I get in these,
I just shake and I went behind the stereo
and I'm behind the stereo
like this, just holding on.
My father said, "What's wrong with you?
"What's wrong with you,
what's wrong with you?"
Again, they had to pull me
from over the fucking stereo.
And so my dad said, "Well it's about time
"to get him into some therapy."
So, I didn't get into therapy
'til later on into life,
but I want to go talk about something else
that's happened in my life.
As a child I was molested
a couple of times.
The first time I was
molested, I had a babysitter.
And my babysitter was about 13 years old.
I still remember her name.
I don't want to put her name out there.
Anyway, so she came over
and she would always
kind of look at me funny.
So, the girl I was telling
you about, named Sonya,
The girl with the rocking
chair, she was over one day.
And we were sitting on
the couch and she said,
"Do you guys like each other?"
So I'm like, "I'm a boy.
"I don't really like no girls."
Oh god, I'm embarrassed to tell this.
So she had me take my index finger,
and rub it on her vagina
and then taste it.
I did that and I remember
when I did that, ugh,
I remember the smell of it
was so, it was like, ugh!
But anyways, as that time went on
it made me curious about,
because I like the way it looked.
I mean, I liked the way
that the vagina looked.
So, about a week later
she was babysitting us
and it was only she and I there,
and she was sitting on the toilet.
I don't know for what in the world reason
made me come up to her.
I walked in the bathroom
and here I'm about six years old
and I said, "Well, let me see it."
And she's sitting like this.
I said, "Well, let me see it?"
She says, "See what?"
I said, "You know."
And now I remember this
like it was yesterday,
I remember she did like this,
and she kind of opened her lips
and she said, "Lay on the floor."
I had no idea why she
said, "Lay on the floor."
I laid on the floor and I
remember I laid on my back.
- [Interviewer] How old
were you at this time?
- I was six years old.
- [Interviewer] Six.
- She was 13.
I laid on the floor and I don't
remember what it felt like,
but I know whatever she did,
she got up on top of me and
she did something like this.
She kept asking me,
"Well, how does it feel?
"Well, how does it feel?"
At first I thought she was
some kind of killer or something.
It scared the shit out of me.
I mean, it scared the
fucking shit out of me.
Then I kind of started to like it,
'cause I mean, she had nice
tits and I'm a little boy
and little boys are curious
about tits and stuff.
So, I kind of liked it.
So, I didn't know that would
carry onto me up to this day,
because I remember I thought.
I've never in my life told nobody.
I remember I thought that
every lady that babysitted me,
was supposed to at least initiate sex.
I don't care if it was my
grandmother, my auntie,
my sister, my auntie, if I
thought she had a nice ass,
even at six years old
and you was babysitting,
we was supposed to do something.
(pop music)
I had a cousin of mine.
I guess she was about 20 years old.
And I used to get bronchitis
and had to go home sick.
I remember I was there
in the living room floor.
I was sitting down watching
"Mighty Mouse" on TV.
She was laying there, she had these--
they used to call them hot pants,
these little hot shorts on,
and she was laying on the
couch kind of like this.
I remember, when she woke
up, I was standing over her,
and she kind of woke up, and
she's, "What are you doing?
"What are you doing?"
And (laughs) I said, "Can I see it?"
She said, "What are you talking about?"
I said, "Can I see it?"
"What the hell!
"I'm your cousin!
"Go in and wash your mouth out with soap."
She told me.
The next thing I know, about
an hour later, she said,
"I'm gonna show you how to do something."
"Okay what are we gonna do?"
I'm thinking, she's goin' get on top of me
and we goin to,
no, she said (laughs),
oh I'm so embarrassed.
She said, "Taste it."
"Oh okay, what the hell, I'll taste it."
So I remember before I did it,
just the smell, ugh, I mean it was just,
now, you know, I kind
of like the smell now
but back then (laughs)
it's like I couldn't,
the smell just something about the smell.
She said, "Don't worry
about the smell, baby.
"Just put your."
I remember she told me,
oh I'm so embarrassed.
I guess it was her clitoris,
it was kind of sticking up
and she said, I said,
we used to call a penis a dinky.
I said, "You got a dinky like me?
"I didn't know women had dinkies."
She says, "No, no."
She said. "Well put your
tongue on the bottom of it."
Here I am six years old.
"Put your tongue on the bottom of it."
And I remember when I put my
tongue on the bottom of it,
she told me, how and
where to rub my tongue.
I remember, I can remember
this, too like it was yes,
I remember, I almost said her name,
I remember her legs were and
she said, "Go a little faster.
"Go a little faster."
I remember her legs were going like this,
I was wondering, "What the?"
No, no, no, no, no.
Now I know it was an orgasm she had.
But I remember when she did that,
I thought she had urined in my face,
because all this stuff was in my face
and it had this, had that bad smell to it.
I remember running to the bathroom.
I said, "Ah!
"I'm gonna tell my daddy what."
She said, "Boy!"
She said, "If you ever fucking
tell anybody what we did,
"I'm gonna, I'm gonna."
(laughs) I don't know how to put it.
So anyway, we did that
and I wanted to you know,
but the other girl had
done it in the bathroom.
I said, "Well, can I do that too?"
And that, day she didn't let me do it.
I think it might have
been about a month later,
and she initiated me when I was sleeping.
'Cause when I'm asleep I
guess 'cause I was always,
always kinky minded, I was
always wanting to hump.
Me and my sisters and brothers
we used to play, we used
to hump on each other
like we were, you know,
like we were having sex.
We didn't know what
the hell we were doing.
- [Interviewer] With your clothes on?
- We did it yeah, we dried fucked all,
we'd call it dry, we did it all the time.
I was the one who initiated all the time
because of what had done I
was always the one initiate it
and plus I just was a little kid,
I used to like to watch it.
Well, one day Yvette and
Angie were the two twins
that stayed next door,
and we had a cardboard box in the backyard
and we had like a gate
where you couldn't see.
So, me and my little brother,
we had Yvette and Angie in the backyard.
I said, I almost said,
I say, "Hey man, you wanna see something?"
And we used to call it the hump.
I said, "Do you want me to
teach you how to do the hump?"
My little brother says, "Well
okay well what is that?"
So oh god I can't even
believe I'm telling you this.
So we have the cardboard in the backyard
and Yvette's laying down.
Angie was the big one,
I always liked fat, kinda heavy.
Angie was the fat one
and I remember we told
her lay down on the thingy
and they didn't want to do it.
I don't know where, I guess
because my dad was always,
I wanted to be,
I thought I was supposed
to be the dominary one.
I said, "Well, oh you goin' do it!
"Oh you fucking goin' do this!"
No, no, I remember she tried to run,
so I remember I grabbed her.
You know, back in the day, women would
always wear the little dresses.
I remember I pull up her dress.
Now I don't know what the hell I,
but I just know I got on top
of her, my little brother,
so all of a sudden, you could
hear boom boom boom boom boom.
"What are you doing on my daughters?
"What are you doing on my daughters?"
Boom, all of a sudden, oh my god.
So, she called the police
on my and my brothers.
And she told my mom, my
mother never told my father.
My father would have killed us.
My mother never told my father but,
word had had it on the whole block,
that me and my brothers, the
women were off limits to us.
From way back, I guess I was about,
I might have been about seven,
and the worlds were off limits to us.
They said we were the
perverts of the neighborhood.
So I remember I had this half-sister.
I didn't really have a crush on her,
but I kinda had a crush on her.
I just liked the way she was thick.
I just liked the way she was shaped,
so I remember I told her one day myself.
"You know what?
"How come you never let me
see you go to the bathroom?"
She said, "What do you?"
'Cause I had a problem with that
'cause I used to like to watch
girls go to the bathroom.
I even one time, I put a
hole in the wall. (chuckles)
I put a hole in the wall,
so I could watch when my sister
would be in there peeing.
I'd be looking through the
hole in the wall, you know,
and be kinda wacking off.
I used to do that,
and that began some real
perverted shit in my life.
So anyway, I remember
when they had a show come
on TV called "Love, American Style".
We weren't supposed to watch that,
so I would stay up late at night,
and my grandfather, they
would be watching it.
And I would look through the door,
and for some reason,
I just thought sex, you had to touch,
you had to screw sumthin'.
I always wanted to screw.
I remember watching
"Love, American Style",
and I wanted to see, I just knew,
I knew they're gonna fuck,
I knew they're gonna fuck.
I said, "I knew they're gonna fuck."
They never did so one day,
I find a porno magazine
that someone gives my
dad, a Playboy magazine.
Now here we go.
I was about maybe six years old.
We moved from where we
were to another place,
and they had white kids where I was goin',
so I see this blonde, this
blonde in the centerfold.
And I remember seeing her.
I was like, "Wow!"
I've seen white people on TV,
but I never really seen one.
So when we went to this other school,
I can't believe I'm finna tell you this,
went to this other school.
I've always been bold.
I've always just asked,
so anyway, I remember my
last name starts with a B,
so her last name starts with a B,
so when they line you up to go to class,
you have to line up in
alphabetical order everyday.
So, I remember when I'm
standing there in line,
and I remember I looked over,
and there was this girl named Ruth.
I remember seeing her shiny blue eyes
and her long thick blonde hair,
and she had long legs, and
she had this little dress on,
and she had this nice little round behind.
I remember I looked at her,
and I remember the teacher asking me,
the teacher was wondering
if something wrong with me,
the teacher told my momma
something was wrong with me
because I couldn't stop staring at her.
I thought that was the most
beautiful fucking thing
I'd ever seen in my life.
I'd seen this white girl standing there,
and I think I had a hard on.
But anyway, so one day,
we were playing this,
where you put the hula hoop on you,
and everybody, I'm watching Ruth doing it.
I said, "Well can I, you know?"
So, one day we were standing in line,
since she was in the
front, I was in the front.
I say, "Ruth, can I see it?"
She said, "What are you talking about?"
I said, "Can I see it?"
I said, "I'll give you a Snicker
bar if you let me see it."
She said, "What do you want to see?"
And I said, "You know."
"Nah, I ain't finna do nothin like that."
So, I guess this is about a week later.
I ask her again, I said,
"Hey Ruth, can I see it?"
Where the classroom, we had our classroom,
room number 19 was on the top.
Now on the bottom, the
restroom was like right here,
so we had to go to the stairs.
Oh god it's so embarrassing.
So we had to go up the
stairs and back to the room.
So anyway, for some reason
we were coming from the,
I don't know where we were both coming,
we were kinda crossing.
And she said, "Hey."
She called me a boy, I guess you know.
"Hey boy, you still got that candy bar?"
She said, "You wanna go in the bathroom?"
I say, "Yeah, we're going to bathroom."
So, I went in the bathroom,
we went in the bathroom,
and she said, "Give me the candy bar."
Oh god, and she just kinda
flashed her underwear like that.
I said, "No no, I really wanna see it."
So I remember when she
opened up her pants,
I put my finger in it.
I wanted, I figured, oh god,
I figured a white woman had a different,
I wanted to know what it tastes like.
Here I am, what am I what,
six, seven years old,
so I remember I put my finger
in there, and I really.
It tastes too bad.
That led on to, some kind of way,
her big brother got word
of what we had done,
and he didn't mess with
me 'cause my brother,
he went and told his mother.
So his mother told the
principal who told my teacher
because they didn't, and
I lied, I lied, I lied.
And my mother told me, "I
know what you fucking did.
"I know what you fucking did."
She said, "What did you do?"
I say, "Ma!"
She said, "No, no, what
did you fucking do?"
I said, "I just, I just."
She said, "Well show me what you did."
I say, "No."
She said, "Show me what you did."
I show her what I did,
so I went on thinking that
was what life was about.
Everybody wanted me to
either put my tongue
or my finger between their fucking legs.
Now as I grew up, I always
had a fucked up self-esteem.
I mean I did think I was handsome,
but I always had a fucked up self-esteem.
I was always a loner, always to myself.
But even to this day,
the traumatization of that fucking bell,
when I hear that fucking bell
ring, the chime of that thing,
it just, god it just drives me crazy.
Anyway we'll go back,
we'll go back, go back.
So when I got to, I had
never have had sex before,
never had sex before.
Then, I was about 16 years old.
And I remember--
- [Interviewer] Well it
sounds like you had did
when you were six years old, no?
- But that, I don't know if that counted.
I guess I did, I guess that's what I did,
but I never, anyways yeah,
I did that at six years old.
- [Interviewer] It's good, yeah.
- Yeah it's just man I--
- [Interviewer] Understood me,
I know what you mean.
- I did Yvette, Angie, I did
the other girl down the street.
I did a few of my cousins,
I humped on my sisters.
Me and my sisters used to do those,
yeah, me and my sister used to hump,
my other cousin, we just humped,
they paid us three dollars to do the hump,
we did the three dollar hump.
If I jump over a little bit,
where I'm going, my
self-esteem was always fucked,
where I'm fucked up now,
my self-esteem was always fucked up.
So I had met this girl when I was about,
I'ma skip, I'ma go back.
I met this girl when I
was about 16 years old,
one of the most beautiful
women in the school.
I walker her home.
I used to like to watch "The Brady Bunch",
so anyway, I carry the books
home for her from school.
So she had me come over her house one day,
and she was doing short-hand,
and I don't know if some psychic,
she said, "Tell me what I'm writing."
I said "You're writing."
She want me to, "You want
me to taste that pussy."
I said it just like that.
She said, "How did you know?
"Let's run up stairs."
Now her I am, don't I never,
I'm scared to fucking death.
She touch me up the stairs.
We rush, she takes me upstairs,
and I remember she had these really pink
lingerie panties on.
And she said, "I don't want you to see it,
"just kinda stick what you got,
"you know, kinda dig it in there."
So I'm thinking,
I'm thinking, "Should I taste it?
"Should I put my finger in it first?"
I didn't want her to know I had,
so I said, "What the hell?"
So I remember I pulled her panties,
and I put my face in there.
I remember thinking back
when I did it with Sand,
well her legs were shaking,
and she kinda did that too.
So anyway I'm thinking,
let me just tell it all.
I've always been kinda big, okay?
So when I had the sex with her,
she said, "God, this the
biggest dick I ever saw
"in my life."
She says, yeah, I do this so fucking good,
so literally, every single
day for about two years,
she was supposed to go to the prom,
and she took her money for the prom
and bought me a brand
new pair of blue Nikes,
so I said, I don't have no conversation,
I don't have no money,
that's how you get paid.
So I've been getting
women for all my life,
fucking eat pussy and fucking 'em,
and I'm getting paid, pretty much.
I'm not saying that to brag,
I'm saying it is embarrassing
because I never thought,
my self-esteem was just all fucked up.
I'ma jump up and then jump back up,
because now, I'm 57 years old,
and old Petersburg don't
jump like he used to.
So I'm having a hard time getting women
because, I don't have nothing.
I don't have nothing,
and they run from me.
Most of the time, I can't get it up,
and they running from me
and all this kinda shit.
But anyway, I say this to say,
from the time I was six years
old, and going in and out,
but all the drama tasted,
what's going on with me,
was basically because I
got molested as a child,
and it really, I never had nobody,
and when the person that
did to me in my family,
I don't give a shit if it was years ago,
I just, I think about that shit,
and sometimes, I get a resentment,
and I treat that person real bad.
I mean I treat that person real bad,
and I never you know, and
I often got mad at her
and wanted to say, "You fucking bitch!
"You know what you fucking did to me!
"That's why I'm using fucking drugs.
"I can't stand the pain
from when I was younger.
"What the fuck you did to me?"
"And I can't talk to nobody."
My fucking father would
have killed that bitch.
So, wow, I can't believe I told that.
So anyway, as I was growing up,
I remember I was thinking
there were my grandmothers,
my aunties, anybody that stay there.
I remember sitting there.
My grandmother liked me a whole lot,
I was her favorite because
I was the black seed
of the family, nobody
never really liked me.
I wore the glasses, I was ugly.
I didn't bathe that much.
I was just lazy and sorry,
just slothful, you know?
And I think I did that to get attention
because I couldn't get
attention no other way,
but I remember my father, I
used to think my dad hated me.
You know, because my daddy,
it was never nothin' positive,
it was always, "You're sorry!
"You're dumb!
"Look at you!
"You can't test!"
And I used to go in my room and just cry.
Man, I used to fucking cry.
I used to want to say, "Dad,
why don't you love me, dude?
"Why do you just step
on me, everything I did,
"everything I said."
I'ma jump up, I'ma jump back.
Even when I had my child, I had
my child in my arms one day,
and son of a bitch, he said,
"Look at Louis playing daddy,
he ain't no fucking daddy."
Could you imagine how that fucking cut me?
I'm sitting there on the side.
"You worthless son of a fucking bitch!"
And I think that's the first time,
because my dad, he
wouldn't let me talk back.
My father was a military, you couldn't.
I hate to go up, it's just
so much I want to tell.
My father, he was the kinda guy,
I remember sergeant told him one time,
he said, "Never take
all of a man's pride."
My father took all my
pride, could never buck up.
I think the first time
I ever bucked up on my,
when he said I was
playing daddy with my kid.
My father had about 30 kids.
I mean literally he has kids,
I think women just
couldn't say no to my dad.
Kids all over the place.
I said, "I'll tell you what partna.
"I know something."
I said, "I got one kid,
I know where my kid is,
"and if I got to spend
any money on my kid,
"I got to spend money on one kid.
"I ain't got fucking kids all
"over the fucking god damn city,
"over god damn Longstar,
wherever they are,
"and got us put all my
motherfucking money,
"my money go right here.
"I know something about
being a fucking daddy.
"Somebody else don't."
I remember my whole,
we used to have these
big dinners in my desk,
knowing the whole family was like,
"God no, he didn't say that.
"I know he didn't say that!"
My father went, "What
the fuck did you say?"
My stepmother said, "Leave him alone!
"Don't you, let him get it out!"
And I cried, I cried, I cried.
He's, "Okay motherfucker,
okay motherfucker."
We never really discuss that but,
it was a good thing that I
got that off of my chest.
I want to see you say,
"You stop ostracizing
me, you son of a bitch."
"You stop downing me and telling me."
To this day dude, I love
to lift young men up.
I never ever would talk down.
I would never ever talk down on a kid.
When they talk down on me,
I remember hearing this lady one time.
She told her daughter,
"Get you sorry ugly ass
"in the McDonald's."
I said, "Whoa whoa whoa
whoa, she's not sorry.
"She's not ugly."
I said, "If you tell her shit like that,
she's gonna grow up fucked up like me!"
I remember that lady.
She looked like one of
them big tough ladies.
She turned and said, "You might be right?"
I mean, that's how they talk to me.
I'm sensitive.
Sometimes I think, maybe my
dad talked to me that way,
because he felt like
I could get some balls
and do something different,
but it didn't work,
like I've been a pussy.
I didn't work that out
of me, it made me feel
god, I always had my head down.
And to this day, I'm a loner,
I don't like being around people,
I don't communicate with people well,
I don't know, I have
crazy fucking thoughts
of fucking people up all the time.
If I see you abusing a kid, I really, oh!
Let me tell you this.
I'm a dog lover, I love dogs.
My fucking father, I'ma
tell you like I feel it.
This motherfucker, we had two Belgians.
My grandfather gave us
two Belgian Sheepdogs,
the most beautiful dogs in the world.
They had our little puppies.
So yeah, he was buying
the food for the dogs.
Well I guess three or four
days, they hadn't eaten.
So I told him when he came.
"Well dad, we need dog food for two,
you didn't bring the dog."
He made us take the puppies
and put 'em in the back of
the fucking pick-up truck,
took 'em to a unknown neighborhood,
and one of them got hit by a car,
and he made us throw
'em out in the street.
Threw the poor puppies in the
middle of the god damn street,
in the fucking street, and
the dogs were screaming.
And he takes off in the truck.
I remember those fucking dogs.
I remember those dogs
looking at me and my brother.
And, we got in the pick-up truck,
and my father looked at us.
I guess the way we looked at him
because my father to this day,
he said, "My sons hated
me ever since I did that."
Man, I wanted to literally push his ass
out the fucking truck
and let him feel how
them fucking dogs felt.
So one day, he was somewhere
out on the fucking street,
fucking around with my mother,
and it came two o'clock in the morning,
somebody domed him, somebody
was how do you say it?
Somebody clipped him, what do you say,
they hit somebody from the side,
they say you'd had t-boned him.
T-boned him and he broke
all his fucking ribs,
so he couldn't work for a long time.
And I remember thinking that
something was wrong with me,
because I was saying,
"Yeah, you motherfucker."
I was thinking to myself.
I'd never said this to nobody.
I was thinking to myself,
"Well yeah, you motherfucker.
"That's what you get
for throwing my puppies
"in the middle of the fucking street out
"in Sarito, some god damn where."
Well one of them got
hit by a car and broken.
Now you see how that feels
you dirty motherfucker.
I love my dad, but I just
wanted to just sit down
and talk to him, and tell him,
"You can't treat your kids like,
"you gotta have your money.
"You're fucking me up dude."
In the long term, I'ma end
up somewhere, duh, like here.
And I can kinda see it,
and this motherfucker even to this day,
if somebody tells me something,
compliments me about something I've done,
all I can hear is my father tell me,
"You ain't shit.
"You ain't never gon' be shit."
I remember that voice,
that voice, that voice,
it's always there telling me,
that I'm not gon' be nothing,
and to this day, I think
that I'm not gon' be,
even when I feel like I'm something,
that voice is always in there,
it's a strong, it's a
strong hold in my mind
that tells me, "You know you can't."
I had a set of drums.
I was a drummer.
And I remember I couldn't keep the rhythm
because I couldn't concentrate
because the voices in the
back of my mind tellin' me,
"Why are you doin' this?
"You can't do this.
"You're sorry, you're
dumb, you're stupid."
I remember when we went
to the barber shop,
and I remember we scored a barber shop
in the real ghetto part of town,
and so all these guys
will come on Saturday.
Oh white mac, they comin'
in, talk the bullshit
about what they line up,
what they bought 'em,
what the kids doin' there.
This one guy looks at me,
now my dad is sitting here.
This motherfucker sitting here.
I'm his son, and the
son of a bitch tells me,
"Guy over here, if you was my son,
"I'd kick your ass every fucking day."
Wait let me finish, don't
stop, I'm really on a roll.
This motherfucker tells me,
"If I was your father,
"I'd kick your motherfucking
ass every motherfucking day."
And I'm like, "What the fuck?"
"You sitting over there
with them glasses on.
"I know you're a pussy.
"You're a punk.
"You're scared to fight."
Now my father is fucking
sit, if I was there,
if that motherfucker told
my son some shit like that,
I probably would whoop in his ass.
My father just sitting there,
"I keep telling him he sorry."
This is what this motherfucker sayin'.
I'm feeling it now.
This motherfucker, he's
agreeing with this motherfucker.
So one day, I don't know, I
couldn't get in the house,
so I broke in the house
to get in the house.
And he said, "You know
what, like that guy said,
"I'ma start kicking your fucking ass.
"I'm just 'gon start, you
just need your ass kicked."
And let me tell you how that made me feel.
That hurt me, 'cause
why am I such a bad guy?
I'm just existing, and I guess
because the way I'm lookin',
I'm just a bad guy.
I never thought I was smart.
I always thought I was a dummy,
because of what I was
told when I was little.
I remember I had this
biology class in high school,
and I remember this big buff
guy liked one of my sisters,
and she said, "If you do bad
on this test, I'ma tell your."
Now if my father heard
I got a fail on a test,
he would beat my ass so fucking bad.
I was afraid of him,
so we had a test on the microscope.
We had to name everything
on the microscope,
and I had failed everything.
And when he said that they
were gonna tell on me,
I took that micro, and for
the first time in my life,
I studied and got everything
right on that micro,
and I remember when she asked,
when Cookie asked
Mr.Purse what did Donald,
he's, "Donald got an A!"
He said, "I always thought
something was wrong with him."
This is what the teacher said.
"I always thought something
was wrong with him because."
My last thing,
"He sits in the front of the class,
"and he never raise his
hand, he never says any,
"he just sits there and
looks at me like this."
And I remember the face she made.
I'm still thinking about
the guy in the barbershop,
then what my dad said,
so I'm thinking I'm ugly.
Then, I'm thinking this
big guy, this big buff guy,
lookin' like Arnold Schwarzenegger,
he's uglier than I am.
And this motherfucker
sitting there making faces.
This is what I look like,
but he got an A on the class.
So I say, "Well god damn,
I guess I can do it."
Let me go back to my father.
It's like a big-time finish
with this motherfucker
'cause he fucked my life up.
I took a Afro-American
class, and I got a B,
for the first time in my life.
I heard fucking history, but
history didn't mean shit to me
because history really didn't
have anything to do with me,
as far as me and my heritage.
I always wanted my
father to be proud of me,
to be happy, do something
to make him proud of me.
I said, "Dad, dad, I got a B!"
You know what this motherfucker said?
"Afro-American history?
"That's a bullshit class.
"That class, it ain't even."
Threw the paper in the
trash, so I feel like,
I wanted him to say,
"Hey man, you finally did something good.
"You finally did something right."
That motherfucker still,
still, had that negative
shit to say about me.
And I just don't know why he hated me.
I don't know why he hated me.
I just don't know why he hated me so much.
But until this day, that shit haunts me,
and cuts me, it really just fucks me up.
But the last time he really ostracized me,
when he told me 'bout my kid,
that I was playing daddy.
As I talk about it, that
shit makes me wanna cry
because I'm like, "Damn, what can I do
"to please you motherfucker?
"Is there anything in the world
I could do to please you?"
So this motherfucker, gets a
new wife, even has new kids.
These kids are all successful.
These kids go to college now,
and I remember being over his house.
I remember seeing him hug
these little motherfuckers.
He's hugging these motherfuckers,
and I'm thinking, "Well,
he never hugged me.
"He never hugged my other little brother."
All he did was talk shit to us.
"Do this, do that."
He never hugged us.
Even when I played football,
that motherfucker never
went to the football game.
He never fucking went.
I played the drum, he never
came to the goddamn game.
My brother was complaining
because he graduated from school.
He said, "Dad, I'm gonna
graduate from school."
He didn't even pay no attention.
And do you know why I never been married?
I can't commit to a women,
'cause I think I'm not
good enough for her.
I don't know as far as of now.
Now that I can't sex no more,
I've never been financially,
I don't know how to.
My dad was so good at paying bills.
He was real smart.
He was good at paying
bills, and being organized.
He never showed me that.
He just said, "Go to school,
you didn't go to school."
But I'm like, "You gonna
tell me to go to school,
"and then tell me I'm too
stupid to go to school.
"Well what the fuck do I do?"
Who do I answer to?
Who do I go to?
I didn't test nobody.
I don't test nobody.
So, I never learned how
to pay pills and budget.
Every time I ever had a job,
I'd get my whole fucking check
and just fucking spend it.
So most of the girlfriends I've had,
they've always been into business.
I didn't have to do none of that.
All I had to do is eat pussy and fuck.
That's all I had to do.
I can't do that shit now.
For like the last five years,
I can't do this shit no more.
I just can't do it no more.
So here I am, and I know even to this day,
I told my therapist, I'm seeing me.
I'm seeing me.
I can see all of me
that I don't let people,
I try, not to let people
dictate my life today.
I am so grateful that the
God sent you to have you,
to have you is so much more.
But just to have you, this
camera here in front of me,
as an outlet to how my
life was really fucked up,
and I can go on and say which way to why,
but it's because my dad
was all I had as a mentor.
And all he did was ostracize me
and fucking kicked me in the ass,
beat my ass and told me I wasn't shit.
And that has a scar on me.
That is a scar on me that,
it's hard to talk about it,
but for some reason, it's
like nobody in the room,
and it's like I'm glad I can sit here
and talk about this shit, you know?
'Cause I always thought that
guys were supposed to be tough
and warm, but I've always played that way,
but I was deep down inside of me,
I was always afraid and scared.
And I always thought I was less than.
I couldn't never fight.
I just never had no self-esteem.
And I'm seeing all that shit now,
when I'm in my own place.
And I lay there and I watch TV.
I don't wanna go no where.
I still think that I'm a nobody.
So when I pick up that bottle,
all that nobody shit goes away.
But then when I come down,
I'm right back there again.
I don't take care of my kid today
because they took my kid from me. (crying)
When they took my kid from me,
they sent to my kid that
shelter, and I couldn't have her.
18 years ago, I have not
lived since that day.
I have not lived since that day.
I have a hatred of myself because of that.
I feel like one more time, I failed.
And that goes to my mind,
almost all day everyday.
I feel like what kind of man,
couldn't get sober long enough,
or his kid wouldn't come out like that.
And I kick myself in the
ass every fucking day.
And I don't care what nobody says.
"You got to forgive yourself."
I can not find it nowhere
in me to forgive myself
for fucking that kid over like that.
I saw that kid shake like
a crack baby one day.
18 years ago, I can't sleep at night
'cause I see that baby shake.
My family, they don't
want anything to with me.
I'm just the worst, I'm really nothing.
I'm really nothing now to
them, I'm really nothing now.
So, in spite of all that,
I'm nothing to me either.
And I walk around here smiling and shit,
like everything is okay,
because that's what they tell me to do.
Hey, everything is not okay,
because I feel really really
fucked up and shitty inside.
And sometimes, I just wanna do crazy shit
just to get off the, you know.
And I got to thank God for alcohol,
because I probably would
have went, just took a gun
and went out there and just
start murdering people.
I think I would've probably
would've bought a gun
and just start shooting motherfuckers.
Because that's the anger and frustration
that I feel inside of me
behind of the bullshit
that's going on in my life.
When they took my fucking kid,
changed my kids name to another name,
and told my kid that I'm not her father,
I'm her uncle, and change her name.
Now if that ain't enough
to make a motherfucker
want to go take a shotgun
and just go blow everybody,
I see why the people go postal.
Because I thought, matter of fact,
when they told me that my
kid wasn't comin' home,
I walked in the liquor store,
and I took the bottle of the rack.
I said, "I'm taking this shit,
"and you ain't gonna do a
fucking thing about it."
And I walked out, didn't
nobody come after me.
Nobody came after me.
I say, "I'm taking this motherfucker,
"and you ain't doing shit about it."
I'm crying.
They just took my fucking baby,
and I need something to drink,
and I ain't got no money dude.
I said, "No disrespect, but
I'm taking this motherfucker."
And they didn't come get me.
I never forget that day.
And that's when I really
knew that the problem
with the alcohol has set in
because an average person,
when you tell somebody that
their kid not coming home
because it's drugs and alcohol.
An average would have quit.
First thing I did was went and got one.
I realize that day, uh
oh, there's a problem.
Something's going on.
There's a problem here.
So, that was all for that.
And, I'm kinda exhausted
from everything I said.
Am I good now?
Wanna keep going?
- [Interviewer] You
want to give it a break,
and do another one later?
- Yeah, yeah yeah yeah.
- [Interviewer] We can do this next week.
- Okay okay okay okay because
I done said a whole lot
of stuff I ain't never told nobody.
- [Interviewer] No, I think
we'll be doing many of these.
- I ain't never told anybody that shit.
But you know what, is it still on?
I feel better because I got off of it,
you know what I'm saying?
My therapist was always telling me.
I went and tell her none of this shit.
Well some of it.
But not the deep, no I
got some more deeper shit.
- [Interviewer] You told me more
than you told your therapist?
- Oh hell yes, because oh yeah,
you don't have a ink pen
in your hand. (chuckles)
You don't have a ink pen in your hand,
and she looks at me, I don't know.
- [Interviewer] I get a lot of shit
from my viewers in my comments
saying I don't pay attention.
And, you see how many people are outside.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah.
- [Interviewer] I'm
supposed to pay attention
to every single story all day long
as people are like, texting
me and everything else.
- But I think for you,
this is better than a college education.
You can learn a lot about
just people in general.
Because you're being human,
because I'm learning.
I went through, I remember
there were these two therapists,
and I remember they said
that 98.9% of families
in America are dysfunctional.
Well that blew my mind
because I thought ours was
the only one that was dysfunctional
because I saw the nice
car in the driveways.
And, in you go in the house,
the police coming over there,
people getting thrown out of windows,
and dogs getting thrown out of cars,
my brother cuss my dad out.
I was 'gon fight him over the extras.
I mean I got a whole lot of shit out,
all the crazy shit.
- [Interviewer] Let's do
some more of these next week.
- [Louis] Okay, sure thing,
sure thing, sure thing.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
All right man, thank you
so much for coming in.
- See you night time, no
problem, no problem, thank you.